j'ai une dernière question à poser à nos
intervenants oui sur ça sur quoi sur ce
que son témoignage parce que c'est
quelque chose venait de montrer on est
contre ce péché puisque vous avez dit
tout à l'heure on le répète mais on le
répétera jamais assez parce qu'en fait
que le fait que les médias des fois on
n'est pas forcément dans le sens où vous
voulez montrer en permanence ça donne
des idées après à certains de nous
rejoindre et de dire à des regards dès
aujourd'hui la réunion a réussi à
obtenir sur quelque chose au niveau des
taxes au niveau du du diesel à bouger
que du coup aujourd'hui se disent il
faudrait quoi faire sur la chose alors
là ce que je veux faire
alors la seule chose que je demanderai
au gilet jaune qui m'écoutent qui nous
écoute parce qu'on est là s'il vous
plaît on est parti sur ligne de conduite
de pacifistes ou on dialogue on s'entend
très bien avec les policiers on boit du
café avec eux on mange des grillades
avec eux et ça il ne faut pas l'oublier
on reste sur ce même cap surtout pas de
violence très bien est ce que ça ça va
tous nous à bravo bravo bravo pour vous
applaudir ballon je me disais que les
policiers étaient avec les gilet jaune à
merci alors juste pour pour pour finir
j'aimerais savoir où autour de la table
franchement là voilà c'est une dernière
question aujourd'hui de vous poser est
ce que vous vous les intervenants autour
de la table vous seriez prêt à mettre un
gilet jaune ce soir
ou est ce que pour vous le symbole est
et voilà et ne vous correspond pas doc
gynéco bien sûr garantissez les propos
les propos continuent à l'énigme
garantissez vos propos de paix les bains
allez allez allez y allez y même
manifestation dans la paire servie mais
on vous entend pas mademoiselle merci
ouais non mais c'est bon alors toi
bernard dit la vérité oui alors je
devais arrêter oui et on ne fait pas de
chichis la chasse pendant quatre jours
de les côtoyer les autres et j'ai la
chance de côtoyer tous les jours
ouais au péage dans le sud et je disais
mais ça se passait et ça bloquait jamais
trouvé les mec très sympa merci que si
je prendrai le gilet jaune je le
mettrais
mon pare brise mais pas sur moi parce
que je suis j'ai faim tout va bien parce
que pourquoi pourquoi je suis
journaliste je trouve qu'un petit aperçu
de ma faute d'accord alors oui là il a
peur on les a pas mis en grève eric dis
la vérité je n'aime pas trop la question
comme elle est posée franchement si
reina mais tu peux tout me dire tu
voyages choisies parce que le
politiquement correct du moment c'est de
dire c'est ça on va le mettre
ouais bien sûr si on est pour le
mouvement on le met sans restriction et
les gens vont applaudir je n'en attends
attends bernard on voit moins cher moi
je suis d'accord ça pollue les
magouilles lemaitre oui c'est vraiment
moi j'ai juste un peu d'être une petite
qualité c'est que j'essaie toujours de
faire attention pour moi même de passes
sombrer dans la démagogie et ça ne fait
pas le gilet jaune je dis je le met pas
les gens vont lui faire quoi ils vont
siffler ce qui n'est pas très redonné
droit pas du 3d non non juste un mec
c'est ici que si vous soulevez s'il
vient la séquence gmi stop au mouvement
la gemmi victimes en revanche et gémit
réussite mais c'est vrai donc moi je ne
mets pas le gilet jaune ce soir même si
je comprends je vais n'ai pas vu et
personne de cyril je ne vais pas me
cacher derrière ce qu'a dit christine
mais j'adhère compétences
moi je considère je suis journaliste que
les médias c'est une partie importante
de la démocratie qu'on peut être pour un
mouvement
mais si on veut continuer à faire son
métier en toute clarté en tout
discernement on ne peut pas épouser des
causes dont je ne mets pas le gilet
jaune bien sûr sans réserve je sais d'où
je viens certes maintenant je fais
partie des privilégiés faut pas se
mentir être docteur c'est pas c'est pas
la misère mais je n'oublie pas que voilà
mon père est venu en france dans les
années 70 que j'ai grandi dans une cité
que j'ai grandi dans un hlm que j'ai
dormi jusqu'à mes 25 ans dans un lit
superposé que désormais aujourd'hui je
comprends la colère des gilet jaune ça
peut faire rire certains mais on a beau
être finalement est déconnectée parce
que finalement ce quotidien ou se plaint
de décence qui augmente
peut-être que ça va me toucher
personnellement mais je comprends la
misère et je comprend justement tous ces
patients qu'ils m'expliquent qu'ils
souffrent et je vois autour de moi les
gens qui n'en peuvent plus les gens qui
ne travaillent qui travaillent et qui ne
gagnent plus d'argent
malgré leurs activités donc bien sûr je
soutiens le gilet jaune et je suis tout
coeur avec vous dans l'enclavé
[Applaudissements]
j'ai le souci de la cohérence
depuis que je décidé de m'engager dans
la vie publique et la cohérence et que
depuis le départ je soutiens ce
mouvement parce que je dis haut et fort
qu'il est légitime et il n'est pas
nécessaire de gagner de smig pour être
solidaires de ce mouvement on peut tout
à fait comprendre que des français
aujourd'hui
travaillant dur et il ya une famille est
obligée de se priver
parce que tout augmente parce qu'ils
n'en peuvent plus c'est pas une société
qui est porteuse d'avenir
et quand je vois des gens qui ne
traitent qui traite de démagogues déjà
qu'ils soutiendraient le mouvement parce
qu'il n'y serait pas concernée
socialement par là moi je dis les gars
il faut ouvrir les yeux on se bat parc
pour soi il faut sortir des égoïsmes un
moment donné quand on a des convictions
avec force
on les défende que sur l'anneau
conscient ou pas je porte le gilet jaune
avec fierté
[Applaudissements]
ça se voit qu'ils aiment ça tout pour
moi mettre le gilet jaune c'est
justement porté haut et fort le message
des pacifistes des gens qui m'aiment et
sage qui nous ont fait passer soir les
messages de cette jeune femme qui a
parlé à plusieurs reprises et qui ce qui
qui qui relaie ce message aussi de
solidarité des gens qui souffrent
aujourd'hui je peux pas dire non sur ton
plateau
je soutiens et je suis complètement
d'accord et je comprends et ne pas
mettre le gilet jaune
je met les jets les jeunes pour moi
c'est dire je comprends je comprends
votre cri je comprends votre soutien je
comprends votre douleur
moi j'ai un papa qu'après 40 ans en
france qui gagne 700 euros de retraite
ne pas mettre le gilet jaune c'est
insulter ce qu'il est alors donc je suis
obligé de le mec mais je ne mets aussi
par conviction parce qu'on l'a entendu
ici depuis plusieurs émissions la
souffrance de ces gens-là et et ouais je
suis pas journaliste mais j'ai pas de
neutralité dont le maire est eric
[Applaudissements]
pour deux raisons j'ai essayé d'éviter
toute la soirée la démagogie c'est pas
pour craquer la dernière semaine
non mais si la ville en ville il peut il
peut prendre comme ça aussi je les ai
ensuite et surtout même un gilet jaune
ça se mérite
donc j'attends d'avoir passé deux ou
trois nuits blanches venez de mme amara
vous voilà enfin j'aurai passé deux ou
trois nuits blanches peut-être que
j'aurais fait n'importe quoi mais là le
corps tu es là alors je vais aller me
coucher tranquille mais ces panneaux
fluorés ya une forme d'art postuler
l'honneur je vous le dis franchement
pour les deux raisons j'ai dit non non
mais c'est quoi c'est qu'on pense qu'il
a raison mais ces conventions c'est vrai
qu'ils ont à vous il y en a plein elle
tous les gilets jaunes les positions
explosé il n'avait donc pas il donne en
pratique man party aux maquilleuses
impasse que la web à ses débuts toi et
toi tout vas toi arrête un peu là par
exemple que 67% des français qui
soutient le mouvement